nous occupons du classement et du
chronométrage découvert grâce à tout
l'équipement que nous mettons sur les
vélos donc ça commence par les
transpondeurs ce sont des puces que nous
plaçons sous les vélos dans chaque cour
a identifié est ici dans le camion
lorsque le coureur passe la ligne
d'arrivée
nous avons une boucle qui capte les
formations et qui remonte
informatiquement donc automatiquement on
a le nom du coureur en azote dossard y
en a 100 ans
donc ici le camion c'est ici qu'on gère
informatiquement tout le chronométrage
électronique
maintenant nous ne saisissons plus le
résultat la main tout remonte
électroniquement donc on a déjà tous les
classements et bien sûr il faut vérifier
quand même les classements grâce à son
appel
la caméra photo finish c'est le juge de
paix c'est le juge de paix on sait
exactement qui est devant qui c'est une
caméra qui fait mon avec une capacité de
7000 images par seconde ont mis en
images par seconde 5000 images par
secondes et vous arrivez dans tout ça à
savoir
quel est le joueur au centième près
exactement arrivé le premier au
millimètre près même une fois il ya une
bonne ambiance dans son camion une bonne
engueulade c'est une équipe qui est
compétente donc mon ami olivier de
performance caraïbes et puis moi même
2000 comme donc nous ce sont deux
sociétés martiniquaise qui se sont
alliés pour proposer une prestation de
qualité au cyclisme en vigueur